what I want to show you in this video is
that implicit differentiation will give
you the same result as I guess we could
say explicit differentiation when you
can differentiate explicitly so let's
say that I have the relationship x times
the square root of y is equal to 1 this
one is actually pretty straightforward
to define explicitly in terms of X to
solve for y so if we divide both sides
by X we get square root of Y is equal to
1 over X and then if you square both
sides you get Y is equal to 1 over x
squared which is the same thing as X to
the negative 2 power and so if you want
the derivative of Y with respect to X
this is pretty straightforward this is
just an application of the chain rule we
get dy/dx is equal to negative 2 X to
the negative 2 minus 1 X to the negative
3 power so that's pretty straightforward
but I want to see is if we get the same
exact result when we differentiate
implicitly so let's apply our derivative
operator let's apply our derivative
operator to both sides to both sides of
this equation and so let me make it
clear what we're doing x times the
square root of y + 1 right over there
when you apply the derivative operator
to the expression on the left hand side
we are just going to have to apply well
after we're going to apply both the
product rule and the chain rule the
product rule tells us so we have the
product of two functions of X you could
view it that way so this the product
rule tells us this is going to be the
derivative with respect to X of x of x
times the square root of Y times the
square root of y plus plus X not taking
its derivative plus x times the
derivative with respect to x times the
derivative with respect to X of the
square root of Y let make it clear this
bracket of the square root of Y of the
square root of Y and on the right hand
side right over here the derivative with
respect to X of this constant that's
just going to be equal to
that's just going to be equal to zero so
what does this simplify to well the
derivative with respect to X of X is
just 1 so we're just going to be left
this simplifies to 1 so we're just going
to be left with the square root of Y
right over here so we're just going to
be this is going to simplify to a square
root of Y and what does this over here
simplify to well the derivative with
respect to X of the square root of Y
here we want to apply the chain rule so
let me make it clear so we have plus
this X plus this X plus whatever
business this is and I'm going to do
this I'm going to do this in blue well
it's going to be the derivative of the
square root of something with respect to
that something well the derivative of
the square root of something with
respect to that something or the
derivative of something to the 1/2 with
respect to that something is going to be
1/2 times that something to the negative
1/2 power
once again this right over here is the
derivative of the square root of Y with
respect with respect to Y we've seen
this multiple times if I were to say the
derivative of the square root of x with
respect to X you would get you would get
1/2 X to the negative 1/2 now I'm just
doing it with wise but we're not done
yet remember our derivative operator
wasn't the same with respect to Y it's
with respect to X so this only gets us
with respect to Y we'd apply the entire
chain rule we have to multiply that we
have to multiply that times the
derivative of Y with respect to X in
order to get the real derivative of this
this expression with respect to X so
let's multiply times the derivative of Y
with respect to X we don't know what
that is that's actually what we're
trying to solve for but to use the chain
rule we just have to say it's the
derivative of the square root of Y with
respect to Y times the derivative of Y
with respect to X this is the derivative
of this thing with respect to X so we
get this on the left hand side on the
right hand side we just have a 0 and now
once again we can attempt to solve for
the
derivative of Y with respect to X and
maybe the easiest first step is to
subtract the square root of Y from both
sides of this equation and actually let
me let me move all of this stuff over so
I have once again more room to work with
so let me let me let me cut it actually
and then let me paste it let me move it
over right over here so we went from
there to there I didn't I didn't gain a
lot of real estate but hopefully this
helps a little bit and actually I don't
even like that let me put it let me
leave it where it was before so then we
if we square if we subtract the square
root of Y from both sides we get and
I'll try to simplify as I go we get this
thing which I can rewrite as as X as x
times well it's just going to be X in
the numerator divided by divided by 2
times the square root of Y Y to the
negative 1/2 is just the square root of
Y in the denominator and 1/2 I just put
the 2 in the denominator there times
dy/dx times the derivative of Y with
respect to X is going to be equal to is
equal to the negative square root of Y I
just subtracted the square root of Y
from both sides and actually this is
something that I might actually want to
copy and paste up here so copy and then
paste so let's go back up here just to
continue our simplification solving for
dy/dx well to solve for dy/dx we just
have to divide both sides by x over 2
times the square root of y so we're left
with we are left with dy DX dy DX is
equal to or if we were dividing both
sides by this is the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal of this is
equal to 2 times the square root of y
over x over my yellow x x times the
negative square root of Y well what's
this going to simplify to this is going
to be equal to Y times the square root
of Y times the square root of Y is just
Y the negative times the 2 you get
negative 2
so you get negative 2y over X is equal
to the derivative of Y with respect to X
now you might be saying look we just
figured out the derivative implicitly
and it looks very different than what we
did it looks very different than what we
did right over here when we just use the
power rule we got negative 2 X to the
negative third power X and X to the
negative 3 power the key here is to
realize that this this thing right over
here we could solve explicitly in terms
of we could solve for y so we could just
make this substitution back here to see
that these are the exact same thing so
if we make the substitution Y is equal
to 1 over x squared you get dy/dx the
derivative of Y with respect to X is
equal to is equal to our negative 2 is
equal to the negative 2 times 1 over x
squared and then all of that over X
which is equal to negative 2 over X to
the third which is exactly what we have
over here negative 2 X to the negative
third power